donald trump fait le forcing
alors que le président américain a
retiré les états unis en 2010 8 de
l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien
conclu en 2015 estimant trop peu
contraignant la semaine dernière
washington a envoyé une notification à
l'onu objectif le retour des sanctions
internationales contre l'iran
notre message est très simple les états
unis ne permettrons jamais aux plus
grands états qui soutient le terrorisme
d'acheter et de vendre librement des
avions des chars des missiles et
d'autres types d'armes conventionnelles
ces sanctions des nations unies
maintiendront l'embargo sur les armes
donald trump s'appuie sur une résolution
particulière le snack bac qui permet à
un état participant à l'accord de
demander un rétablissement des sanctions
s'il juge que cet accord a été violée
pour les états unis l'accord n'est plus
valable
l'iran ayant violé sa promesse de ne pas
développer d'armes nucléaires nous avons
rappelé aux membres notre droit en vertu
de la résolution 2231 de déclencher un
retour en arrière et notre ferme
intention de le faire en l'absence de
courage et de clarté morale de la part
du conseil
la demande américaine a été rejetée
mardi par la présidence du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies pour 13 des
15 membres les états unis n'ont plus de
base légale pour déclencher une
procédure de snap bac ayant perdu leur
statut d'état participant à l'accord du
gouvernement iranien n'était donc pas
inquiet c'est une résolution très
inégale et en fait elle utilise les
mécanismes du conseil de sécurité pour
détruire le conseil de sécurité je suis
persuadé que cette résolution sera
également rejeté le mécanisme de retour
en arrière est parfaitement clair et
juridiquement parlant
l'amérique n'a aucun droit de l'utiliser
alors que l'embargo sur les armes à
destination de l'iran expire au mois
d'octobre locataire de la maison blanche
semble déterminé à créer une crise au
sein du conseil de sécurité de l'onu
son objectif semble clair tenter de tuer
l'accord sur le nucléaire avant les
élections ou le rendre très difficile à
remettre en place même en cas
d'alternance à la maison blanche